girlfriend are you crazy chicken you
just left your job said goodbye to your
boss and you're starting your own
restaurant why actually equity baby
that's what it's all about
you're not you are now good luck I'm
gonna come and eat there better be good
you'll be dead to me just start over
thanks man hey you like everybody
they have every high-end brand in the
world here and what's interesting is
sometimes I have unique pieces so
they'll say ok we have a collection in
here Paul tried it on
get the wheels now as it's really tough
this is really a talk show very Rob this
is the watch that I need good fries Rob
get their wheels rolling nobody's tried
it on and it feels me it's gotta be part
of aesthetics killed it's gonna be a big
[Music]
we're gonna go right to the moment that
you have just walked over so meat
plating the box you guys have already
met so this is meat potatoes yeah and
you know the reason why we didn't let
you see the watch is so that we can
experience this moment with you to the
next thing ready I'm ready
okay so first of all super happy that
you know that this free but mind could
have left it behind this watch very
special for the brand so you drink much
1972 when the world over which we came
out is a super controversial
[Music]
[Music]
we are at the headquarters of rubber be
actually a swiss company that makes very
specialized bands for all kinds of very
high-end watches they're the only
company I use because their integration
with the case is perfect now you know I
only want to read that on a watch
particularly I watch one where on
television who makes them for me
rubber B so watch by watch sometimes
they have to make unique band or
one-of-a-kind sometimes they've already
got it in stock I stopped a Benjamin to
CEO all the time we discussed these
integrations and today we're going to
put a rub them a rubber be red band on
three watches that are going to go on
short tail so I've got some very very
interesting stuff to show you let's have
some fun first the only one with a red
band and for six weeks we argue about it
cause they don't have to change much oh
it's black in the bottom I've been close
could you see the fetching yeah try it
off
[Music]
it's bigger than I thought
41 and it looks it looks very balanced
the curvature of the crystal makes it
look bigger than it is it looks bigger
very strange we'll see what hospital
currently the crystal is basically it's
like a magnifying glass on top of the
watch and that's what looks like a few
millimeters to it it's very strange
optical illusion because if it's a it's
light and it fits in a very sleek way
but it looks beefier
[Music]
without her
in other word select say it took them
four months we have an electric ride the
new cultural boroughs that color lets
you make it usually she did and they
look great on television avoid protests
this is my Japanese
[Music]
this is the only one now that you've
made it now you can make more really we
didn't do a pink walk or do you have
this is a one of a kind but he would be
a one of a kind
what do you mean the shade no no this
band is the only one in the world for
that watch for that rule don't make it
follow you're gonna make it as a thing
but we know that the tiger because the
watch is rare know what she's difficult
to get but where she is only one of the
Shepherd and we did the black and women
up to want it but we did the red one on
forgetting we had one common thing is
the knife exactly
that is absolutely beautiful hey just
look look how it pulls that ran out of
there
batman batgirl I wore it once in New
York with just the steel band on it
people win a mess we're just a new
movement it's got the new Rolex I
[Music]
apologize subscribe to my channel you
know what happens you'll be dead to me
[Music]